[Musique]
quoi toi jeune qui a tout intérêt à
rejoindre les républicains en 2020 alors
que beaucoup disent que le parti des
républicains est en partie mort un parti
qui est dépassé et bien parce que les
républicains donnent la parole aux
jeunes ils ont su joindre les paroles
nos actions en organisant ce magnifique
rassemblement de port marly où plus de
mille jeunes se sont rassemblés et on a
pu débattre échanger partager de bons
moments et cela montre bien que notre
parti s'est rassemblée sa jeunesse mais
également parce que les républicains et
bien constitue la force majoritaire de
droite la force majoritaire qui défend
les valeurs de la droite aujourd'hui
parce que les républicains défendent le
gaullisme les républicains défendent la
méritocratie les républicains défendent
l'intégration plutôt que le
communautarisme
donc si tu crois en ses valeurs eh bien
tu as tout intérêt à t'engager auprès
des républicains et à faire en sorte et
bien que notre france retrouvé de sa
superbe
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]